[Musique]
réaliste tribal old school japonais il y
en a pour tous les goûts et pour tous
les tatoués le Mondial du tatouage c'est
le rendez-vous immanquable des
passionnés
myan
John des tatoueurs venus du monde entier
pour participer à l'événement parmi eux
Dimitri ashka yvelinois il a commencé sa
carrière en 1990 au valfouret à
mont-laajolie aujourd'hui cette star du
tatouage français est installée à
Saint-Germain en lait il est l'un des
invités de marque du Mondial c'est l'un
des plus gros événements de la planète
quand même dans le tatouage donc on a de
la chance parce que ça se passe à Paris
et donc c'est voilà c'est une convention
exceptionnelle tu as les meilleurs
artistes de toute la planète qui sont
représentés ici aujourd'hui le tatoueur
est en pleine démonstration il réalise
une pièce assez importante sur la cuisse
de Coralie une jeune ivelinoise ok on
estti déjà plus de 3h que la jeune fille
est sous les aiguilles de Dimitri pour
espérer se faire tatouer par l'artiste
il faut être patient parfois même plus
d'un an avant de pouvoir passer entre
ses mains Coralie elle a attendu un an
et demi avant de faire réaliser son
projet par le tatoueur j'adore son style
ça marque on lui demande quelque chose
et il rajoute toujours quelque chose à
lui et c'est c'est vraiment cool là on a
des clients d'un peu d'un peu partout
qui peuvent venir bon après j'ai quand
même plus une clientèle de de France
quand même le tatouage maintenant c'est
un peu comme tous les arts on va dire la
bande dessiner la peinture quoi tu vas
pas acheter le la peinture du mec à côté
de chez toi si ton voisin il peint des
trucs qui plaisent pas donc maintenant
les tatoueurs peuvent faire des
kilomètres pour aller voir le tatouur
qu'ils aiment bien et tatouer un truc
est dans le style qu'il veul le style du
tatouage de Coral le trash polka un
univers sombre et stylisé très en vogue
une des spécialité de Dimitri pour moi
c'est c'est vraiment des signification
et le tatouage c'est unevre une vre
éternelle sur un support
éémè et encore quelques surs de courage
pour la jeune fille avant de pouvoir
repartir avec un souvenir inoubliable de
ce Mondial je pensais pas
ça c'est du tatouage ça fait mal he
sinon on en aurait encore plus en 26 ans
de carrière l'artiste a vu le monde du
tatouage évoluer aujourd'hui un Français
sur 10 serait tatoué quand j'ai commencé
à tatouer je tatouais plus des loulous
des militaires des des brigands des
punks des skinad voilà des des gens
plutôt marginaux on va dire et et puis B
maintenant tout le monde une évolution à
l'image du mondial en 3 jours
l'événement a accueilli plus de 32000
visiteurs mais l'histoire ne dit pas
s'ils sont tous repartis
tatouer